North Carolina Surgery Clinic has just
been caught performing the gender
surgery on young girls as young as 14
the Cosmetic concierge which is a
Plastic Surgery Clinic in Charlotte
performed elective double mastectomies
on these young teenage girls including
at the very least one 14 year old this
according to reports from Redux they've
got images of this it's not even just
records they've got images showing the
results of Top surgery procedures which
is where these quacks chop off the
breasts healthy breasts of young girls
who are having a little bit of body
discomfort as they go through puberty
you know like every single teenage girl
ever in human history well what they
decide to do is chop off their healthy
body parts photos include lots of other
girls too though 16 16 year olds 15 year
olds and and 14 year olds this is
happening don't let them tell you that
this isn't happening